the live service model of games has led
to a lot of half-baked releases a lot of
games have been left forgotten but many
have also had the chance to redeem
themselves with enough post-launch
support decent content updates and a
supportive fan base plenty of games have
gone through a redemption arc of sorts
but how does redemption work in games in
this video we're going to establish what
redemption looks like when it comes to
video games and use battlefield 2042 as
the first prime example
by tracking its journey across this
redemption arc we can see where the game
currently stands and what work still
needs to be done
so if we're going to properly break down
this arc for games i'm going to
establish a few phases we've got the
cleanup phase cut your losses and double
down identify a supportive audience and
finally build the game to what your
audience wants the last one might seem
really self-explanatory but because
these games are essentially living and
they're always being updated it's so
crucial to adjust your game based on
player feedback so the first phase of
redemption in these games is what i want
to call the clean up phase many of these
games were shipped out sadly in
incomplete and unacceptable states
enabled by this modern life service
philosophy of ship now fix later i don't
like it either trust me the obvious
first order of action though is to clean
up these bugs and glitches and get the
moment-to-moment functions of the game
to what it should have been at launch
you guys remember assassin's creed unity
and mass effect andromeda right
those were bad but live service
multiplayer games are almost worse when
they are busted since one buggy [ __ ] up
can ruin the simultaneous experience of
up to every player in the lobby which in
2042's case goes up to 128 players
beyond bugs maybe there are other
qualities or gameplay mechanics that
fans of each series just couldn't get
behind in the context of 2042 it was
specialist and ho boy i get annoyed by
the intro quips before each match like
everyone else or even the lack of
quality of life features that the
fanbase was expecting like a scoreboard
the cleanup phase should ideally address
it as much as possible as fast as
possible before players start leaving
and even after players leave or have
left you cannot give up on cleaning up
your game hello no man's sky from
getting the game to function reliably
and as intended to giving up certain
gameplay mechanics or systems that the
fanbase targeted as an issue or
potentially problematic within reason so
once all that is taken care of the next
step is what i like to call the cut its
losses and double down phase something
that battlefield 2042 really needs to do
it's time for some soul searching
cyberpunk 2077 which is also undergoing
its own redemption journey ended up
letting go of multiplayer to focus on
fleshing out the rpg systems and economy
so like 2042 can do something similar
and you know just take a deep look in
the mirror see if there's a commitment
to the game for the long term or if it's
just going to be placed on life support
until an eventual sequel
if dice has any interest in retaining
enough players and especially if they
want to harbor goodwill they will want
to commit to 2042 as much as they can
now assuming the game isn't just playing
second fiddle to the development of a
sequel there are two important standout
qualities to this phase in plain english
i mean that this is the part where the
game needs to tap into what makes the
game good in the first place for
battlefield the way to go is by moving
away from a hero shooter and getting
back to the sandbox
keep in mind this doesn't just mean
delete all specialists as much as i know
all you guys in the comments would like
that but you gotta make them more
similar to the tried and true class
system at the same time games might need
to abandon some of these mechanics or
systems that are causing roadblocks even
if they're a big part of the original
vision forget everything that doesn't
serve the primary thing that makes a
battlefield game stand out i'm talking
about things like breakthrough as a
primary game mode awesome destruction
that affects matches in different ways
in a proper and distinct class system on
an optimistic note for you players who
might have already abandoned the game
take my word for it it does seem that
dice has started work on both of these
actions i mean they've cut their losses
right hazard zone i barely even know
what's going on in that game mode
anymore and it seems like dice doesn't
know either and they've poured instead
all of their attention and focus into
shaping all out warfare and another
thing they've abandoned that's kind of
big was they were pushing these 128
player servers all the time but now
they've kind of moved it out of the way
and they're reprioritizing the classic
64 player servers which feel really good
by the way
dice has also doubled downed on their
current maps and instead what they're
doing is they're adjusting them to fit
the world a bit better
they've added more cover and they've
been moving around some hopeless
objectives and those who played at
launch might have noticed how clean
these maps were even with destruction
which did not fit the themes in the
world of the game that was being shown
off so far in cinematic trailers or
descriptions i mean it definitely didn't
seem like a huge notepad scrimmage could
break out at any time i mean maybe a
[ __ ] janitor fight broke out here
it's so squeaky clean but during the
preview event for season one a while
back i saw kaleidoscope in a before and
after scenario and noticed dice was
adding more decayed and destroyed
buildings more cover like toppled
sandbags at specific choke points and
overall giving the level a bit more life
and character another thing they've had
to double down on which might be
controversial for you guys in the
comments right now is keeping
specialists but just hear me out i think
there is a world where dice can both cut
their losses with specialists while
maintaining their presence in the game
yes specialists are cheesy and they all
had the same dumb lines and little else
to contribute and they also just seemed
incredibly at oz with the tone of the
world building and lore similar to the
squeaky clean maps that were you know
sponsored by clorox or whatever and i
get it there wasn't any counter play
even for a hero system like boris's
turret countering sundance's wingsuit
which would have been a clear no-brainer
by the way but okay over time the
specialists have been tweaked certain
specialists have their abilities
reworked like rao and angel and angel's
case has revived grant ammo and with the
quality of life updates like scoring you
have support specialists well
actually acting like support seriously
support and even medic players are on
point these days like trust me i'm
surprised too now i think specialists
could stand to be adjusted a little bit
more like mckay still says something
really dumb about wanting coffee or some
[ __ ] before the game loads but hopefully
it won't be like how it was at the
launch for much longer as i said i know
a lot of you guys do not like
specialists but sadly i think they are
too baked in to be fully removed at this
stage which you know what maybe that's
okay and we make our peace with it
because 2042 can serve a new audience
alongside the players sticking it out
kind of like battlefield hardline the
live service model of 2042 had committed
to at least a handful more specialists
revealed with each new season and all of
this was promised pre-release and before
the negative feedback so they kind of
dug their hole in already and they have
mentioned that they are working on
regrouping specialists back into a
proper class system for season 3 which
yes finally and i have my fingers
crossed please get this right dice one
last quick note i want to make is
highlighting how good breakthrough is
and that it might be time for dice to
start looking at breakthrough as its
golden mode instead of conquest at least
specifically for battlefield 2042 the
maps are so large and unwieldy at times
and is hard to hone in on sectors
without being incredibly scattered
breakthrough cuts off so much of the
randomness and combines chaos with
structure and the outcome is just pure
mwah
am i biased yeah battlefield 1's grand
operations were some of my favorite game
modes ever and breakthrough is basically
the same mode just without the crazy
behemoths the maps shine on this mode
and i think that they should capitalize
on this so with phase 2 the double down
and cut your losses were kind of past
the bulk of the redemption arc and we
start to approach phase three so with
all the soul searching and some tough
decisions being made we are truly at a
crossroads here on the one hand if dice
nukes everything and starts from scratch
it'll be too late in my mind i mean
really starting from scratch makes sense
just for a sequel like battlefield 7 and
the crowd that is interested in that has
most likely already left battlefield
2042 but i mean on the other hand they
have a formula that still attracts some
people and even newer people that aren't
allergic to the idea of specialists i
mean the game is not completely dead i
assure you i play every now and again
couple times a week and lobbies are
always full the people who have stayed
are playing the game in my mind the way
that it was meant to be played even
though we're all kinda grumpy about it
on the comps to their credit a lot of
helicopter pilots are absolutely cracked
out and medics are doing their job well
you know sometimes and i'm rarely
wanting for ammo or nades because
support specialists are holding down the
fort at choke points when those stars
align i
i mean it feels good because i think the
most important thing we all need to
consider is this battlefield's core
gameplay is fun to many people
full stop
it's just hard to get back to the chaos
when your foot touched the wall and now
you can't be revived but it's just a
fence
i know
it's just a fence no don't do this man
and when that bug finally is patched a
new one takes its place that breaks all
immersion there's just so much jank and
mess even after all their patches that
you must be incredibly generous to
overlook a lot of this and it's just
frustrating because it's a lot of fun
when things don't break every other
round so the positive thing here is that
dice is starting to add more fuel to the
fun fire and direct its attention to
tweaking the other stuff the limited gun
pool in vehicles they all put a cap on
just how much stuff we can throw around
to add to the chaos which thankfully
they're addressing that because we're
getting more weapons and better synergy
between battlefield portal and
battlefield 2042 we could definitely use
more of this which thankfully season two
is doing just that now season one and
two are kind of the first steps and i
honestly think the new maps they really
rule on season one especially on
breakthrough the transition from high
ground to the quarry of that map to the
opposing home base had a really pretty
wicked cool flow now season two seems
promising as well still falls a little
short in my mind cause i truly do not
give a rat's ass about the new
specialist but the core specialists
we've had so far they covered enough
bases and i'm looking forward to seeing
how season three plays out which seems
to have finally found that middle ground
by getting these specialists into true
assault recon support and engineer
classes as mentioned earlier now during
our preview event for season 2 it was
nice seeing new weapons and some
battlefield portal weapons unlockable in
all out warfare the new map stranded
also seemed really cool and considered
the more popular 64 player servers
because engagements felt much tighter
while still giving room for the
traditional battlefield absurdity like
flying a helicopter into the cargo ship
so all that was sick as hell the battle
pass stuff on the other hand i i didn't
really pay attention to but that's all
nice to have and it's cool adding skins
to all your stuff but
me personally i'm playing the game to
parachute into hellfire whether boris
wears a santa claus outfit or not it's
not as important to me
so season one told me that dice might
still have some spark in them and season
two has some long overdue adjustments
added as well this is all a positive
trend in my mind and i'm really looking
forward to season three depending on how
far off battlefield 7 will be we could
potentially have something on our hands
a few seasons down the line in 2042
all of this taps into the potential for
a supportive audience people want
battlefield 2042 to be good especially
those who still played the game maybe
the solution is by finding a completely
new audience but other games that have
found redemption they tend to identify
this kind of hybrid audience that share
common feelings
destiny and destiny 2 are probably one
of the best examples of games that have
redefined themselves and their audience
for nearly eight years now at certain
point bungie stopped twisting its own
arm to satiate the players that have
left who demanded an impossible amount
of content every other week and instead
they prioritized the audience that
decided to stay for the new seasonal
model sadly you really can't win them
all but the priority needs to be the
audience that is playing your game today
once you've targeted who is playing your
game still despite the rough edges and
what will keep them in your game that
needs to be the next point of action all
right if you're with me so far we're
here now in phase four which is now to
build the game into something that your
new audience or your hybrid audience
wants
if you shape the game into what your
audience is looking for you are well on
track to having a game successfully
redeem itself battlefield 2042 just
isn't quite there yet although i hope i
really really really hope that they get
there at the moment based on my own
little rubric it's more like they're
still somewhere between phase 2 and 3
and they're doubling down on their
sandbox starting to cut their losses
just a little bit but i have hope just
look at their past games battlefield 4
was garbage for like a whole year right
and now it's my favorite battlefield
ever it is worth mentioning that
battlefield 4 had the premium pass but
that's a different discussion now unless
dice plans to keep this content going
for another couple of years to where the
game becomes worth playing in 2042 it
might not be enough battlefield 7 is
already in pre-production although for
how long remains to be seen but if they
can stay the course and focus on
reworking specialists into a class
system add more tools to the sandbox
chaos and reshape the maps to fit the
world a bit more
i mean these are all serious
improvements to be made for the better
and throw some more quality of life
tweaks they could have something really
good here so to summarize all this stuff
neatly for 2042 to be redeemed it's got
to clean up its act cut some of its
losses from its original vision and
prioritize what the current players want
they should double down on the elements
that make the game fun and embrace that
perhaps this is the time to start
building some goodwill especially if
they want any of us to trust their
handling of battlefield 7. alright guys
if you made it this far and have any
ideas for what battlefield 2042 needs to
redeem itself sound off also any
suggestions for other games that you
love that need to be redeemed or have
been redeemed let me know in the
comments i'm looking to make more videos
just like this and i've got a bunch of
fun games i love in the pipeline ready
to break down that have gone through
this redemption process for you
battlefield fans here talk to me let me
know if you left or have stuck it out
but are still hoping for more if you're
in the minority and love this game speak
up i want to hear from all of you just
keep the comments respectful and i'll
pop in and chat with you guys personally
when it comes to shooters i'm neck deep
in destiny's newest season but we've got
modern warfare 2's beta real soon so
follow me on twitter sub to gamespot and
keep an eye out for our future coverage
of all things shooters right here at
gamespot until next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you